le plus difficile c'est pas aller
déjeuner dîner chez les gens tous les
jours parce qu'ils passent leur vie à
nous inviter
et comme il ya quand même quelques bons
vins dans la région il faut faire
attention aux agapes belle bouche est un
type café le thé 15 ans dans l'armée qui
a fait l'indochine qu'a fait l'algérie
son père était boucher avant lui dans un
petit village de dordogne et un jour et
le père est mort et le type est libéré
de l'armée vient reprendre la boucherie
le périgord et le est un foyer
préhistorique très important et le j'ai
besoin de ces évocations préhistorique
pour le pour le film en particulier tout
ce qui concerne cro magnon car justifie
légèrement le boucher un un être humain
qui ont un peu un peu primitif il ya une
institutrice qui qu'il impressionne
beaucoup
je crois qu'il aime beaucoup mais elle
ne veut rien avoir d'affaires physique
avec lui alors sacrée des rapports à
turbigo est lui aussi un peu bizarre si
de ce côté là et puis il ya des meurtres
et des sommes se signer dans les bois
mais parce que sa mort à la france il
est passé six heures due to absolument
pas il en est celle comme tous les
autres clients il est très gentil il est
pas fiers du tout par pierre il
s'approprie à tous les milieux je crois
même série que la plupart du temps des
écrans vidéo
je savais qu'ils allaient polonais sont
déjà meilleur mais tu ferais quoi pour
un mondial est en concert d'habitude
alors libre ou de mettre des endroits
comme ici on servait les écrevisses soit
pas de chèque en aviez crise
périgourdine ah ça c'est vraiment toi
ils sont formidables et rapport avec les
avec les gens ne sera pas là parce que
ça tient peut-être au fait qui tourne
dans le film je veux dire comme tout le
monde joue un le boucher jeu voulant
chez que comme ils sont acteurs kadhafi
tourné en chaise de ils font comme nous
ils retournent dans leurs loges et
s'étonne que je suis leur tour de
revenir j'ai joué avec une pièce avec
stéphane audran et alors le
notre scène quand je livre mes pièces
montées là nous sommes seuls avec mes
mails envoyés à l'école y encore une
scène dans l'école à 7 un phénomène qui
pour les enfants est merveilleux cette
expérience qu'il ne pouvait pas espérer
connaître dans la vie et que brutalement
ils le vivent nous pouvons découvrir
toujours prôné n'aime pas vraiment ça
et on a fait je n'ai pas vu mais on a
fait des promenades dans les grottes et
tout ça avec le gosse et il avait des
petites phrases a dit elle était
formidable formidable les gens du pays
aussi boucher boulanger tout sa tournée
pour moi est un plaisir j'aime mieux
tourner hors de paris déjà et puis
effectivement je trouve assez lecture
bon
n'utilise presque jamais
et décors de la province française
toujours les mêmes endroits qu'on a
visités et darden c'est magnifique et ça
a été très très rarement exploité
je pense qu'on a pratiquement jamais
fait de film en ardèche sais pas si
ridicule on n'a pratiquement jamais fait
filmé dans les vosges c'est absurde
alors c'est une c'est un grand village
d'acteurs y sillage pas combien
d'habitants très malin mais comme tout
le monde joue dans le film tout le monde
attend la grande scène d'ailleurs il ya
un mariage en tout le pays va venir aux
banquiers
[Musique]